let's talk about the nuclear football
and mar-a-lago this past weekend during
I don't even know what number vacation
this was for Donald Trump and in the
first in the early weeks of the
presidential administration Trump was
having dinner at his Florida mansion and
Club mar-a-lago with the Japanese Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe a and while they
were there news broke that North Korea
had just tested a ballistic missile so
instead of saying oh wow this is an
issue of national security we need to
get privacy we need to have this
discussion about a potential
international crisis in a private space
Trump just stayed sitting there at the
table in the middle of a crowded patio
and had his aides come to him to discuss
what was going on tons of pictures were
made public about this here's a picture
of a discussion going on you'll see like
a bright cell phone light there and what
was reportedly going on was aides were
using their cell phone flashlights to
further illuminate some of the sensitive
documents that were relative to this
discussion this is a sort of like a my
pet goat moment when George W Bush on
9/11 was reading to students at an
elementary school obviously not to the
same degree but this type of public
situation and george w bush handled it
way better than donald trump did it's
amazing how the donald trump presidency
has had me praising george w bush more
than once trump and his staff exchanging
extremely sensitive and potentially
classified information with one another
in public and donald trump endlessly
slammed hillary clinton during the
campaign for how she handled classified
information carelessly and look at
what's going on now the White House has
now denied any of the documents were
classified but there's no denying that
they were sensitive here's where it gets
even nuttier there is an army officer
with donald trump with any president at
all times who carries what's called as
the nuclear football it's a briefcase
has the materials needed to launch a
nuclear strike during the dinner at
mar-a-lago the officer who does this was
posing for pictures with random people
including one random dude who was just
eating at mar-a-lago a guy named Richard
D Agassi oh the army officer
Diageo who he was and that he's the guy
carrying the nuclear launch technology
in a briefcase and the agha CEO casually
posted the pictures to his Facebook page
boasting about how he got to meet the
guy who carries around the nuclear
football uh I I can't even make sense of
what's going on Pat unfortunately an
investigation has been launched into
this it's not just liberal hysteria over
anything the Trump administration does
the House Committee on Oversight and
Government Reform is saying we need
proof that this entire debacle wasn't a
security breach of sorts and remember
Donald Trump is the guy who criticized
past administrations for being too open
about their military and intelligence
policy and that he would be more
spontaneous yeah I don't think we're
gonna be seeing much of that this is
like Biff Tannen from the Back to the
Future movies running the United States
Biff Tannen a character played by actor
Thomas F Wilson does anybody feel safe
with what's going on matters of national
security being discussed in what's
effectively a public place not literally
like it's a private club where you have
to pay for a membership but they're in
an open patio and pictures are being
taken Trump's not taking the daily
intelligence briefings when he takes
them there three to five bullet points
and mostly pictures on a single page I
genuinely don't feel particularly safe
right now in terms of the administration
handling and being aware of all relevant
information well according to some of
the back to the future staff the
character Biff Tannen was actually
inspired by Donald Trump and was that
true yeah I mean to the greater point I
mean we have a child in office but yeah
it's an interesting tidbit there
absolutely disturbing and by the way and
the next thing I want to talk about this
is not the only investigation that's
going on with the Donald Trump
administration today's show is brought
to you by go daddy where you can buy
your own domain name build a website or
use any of Go Daddy's business tools you
can save 30 percent at Tri godaddy.com
slash David GoDaddy has actually been
the official host of the David Pakman
show website for many many many years
the 24/7 customer support has been a
very good thing for us I've called them
at really odd
times when we've had website issues and
they are always available they are the
largest domain registrar and whether you
have a new idea you're an established
business you're creating a personal
website or moving your large enterprise
site over to GoDaddy they can do it all
thirteen million customers try it and
get 30 percent off at try go daddy.com
slash David